Cuál es el objetivo de Corea del Norte
con estos lanzamientos porque ahora
Hola buenas tardes bueno esta pregunta
tiene varias respuestas Yo diría que la
más inmediata es que Estados Unidos con
Corea del Sur y Japón estaban llevando a
cabo los ejercicios militares en la zona
de la Península y bueno Corea del Norte
Me parece que son como decimos marcar la
cancha que hizo mandar una advertencia y
quiso Mostrar que ellos también están en
capacidad de hacer daño si son atacados
o sea creo que hay un mensaje de
respuesta de reacción a los ejercicios
militares creados por los tres países
aliados entonces usted dice que es una
mensaje de respuesta no hay una amenaza
real detrás de estos lanzamientos
un misil de Corea del Sur se estrelló
con un problema
mecánico de lo que sí podemos decir
también es que Corea del Norte está
aprovechando un momento en que la ONU
está paralizada está bloqueada
básicamente por Alianza ruso china que
también evita que sean castigado puesto
lanzamientos en cada vez que el Consejo
de Seguridad pretende tomar algunas
sanciones extra es bloqueado o se usa el
derecho abeto de Rusia y de China Por lo
cual también Corea del Norte se siente
con las manos libres para poder mejorar
y trabajar en su propio Arsenal militar
Y cuál Debería ser la respuesta de Japón
y de su Aliado Estados Unidos ante esta
amenaza ante estas advertencias por
parte de Corea del Norte Bueno estamos
en un momento complejo de la política
internacional donde no hay reglas de
juego donde se está redefiniendo el mapa
del poder global los actores quién manda
Quién tiene más poder que el otro creo
que estamos viendo una etapa de
incertidumbre que esto abre la puerta de
la violencia Y lamentablemente esto no
parece ser de que finaliza a corto plazo
sino más bien vamos a vivir tiempos
complejos Y tenemos acostumbrarnos que a
que sea así y digamos no quiero decir la
palabra rezar porque es capaz de lo
humano pero re aseguramos de que no haya
ningún accidente ningún error Ni que
nadie haga una locura Y para concluir
usted hacía referencia recientemente a
este desarrollo nuclear de Corea del
Norte Como un país tan pobre y tan
aislado tiene este potencial
armamentístico bueno básicamente es un
país muy particular ya viene la etapa de
la Guerra Fría
de algún modo Ha logrado mantener el
control El dominio sobre la población es
una dictadura y bueno con tecnología
china rusa logrado sobrevivir Pero bueno
es un caso muy particular